yo what's up guys the prestige Mendeleev
you here and got another game of a exact
same law did you guys say no no Teddy's
new all right so one trained and one
another fanmade map and are we all
cactus no this is whether this goes in
let's go with him alright so yeah cactus
we have realized was opee so yeah oh oh
how much knock back to this is whole
that's only one not back it's quicker
I've tested probably oh hello oh oh I
like getting spawn killed that's what I
like even like this oh my gosh no no
stop you're not spawn killing me again
no bad where where'd you go where'd you
get what though where'd you go what the
heck where'd you are you your butt no
that's a random guy steady a Yeti that
is not the same guy what the hell what
happened we need to go get agent I think
I think oh oh hello hello oh no no hits
no hits okay ah there we go finally got
a kill I like I have been spawned killed
like 17 times I'm I go right in here so
I can't be hit off the map by evils none
of you gonna hit me off the map oh there
we go there we go that Golden Apple
though you have a golden apple I had one
you pick up any items on the ground I
have not found a single item I found an
item like on my first game it was a fire
in SPO Shin when I was facing the guy
that had a silverfish so that was good
that was very helpful take on okay just
move like
I'm just scared to move yeah I'm just
hiding I'm hiding because I got spa like
I think every death except one was bond
kill was Vaughn kills the stupid knock
back though that from now on now I'm not
doing any more community maps I'm not
doing no more community maps because
they all or have way too many
opportunities for you to hit off the map
oh no oh no oh no oh no somebody help me
somebody help me kill teddy no okay oh
you kill each other yeah you kill each
other all right hey watch this I'm your
agent let's finish this thing nope oh is
it a chase the chase I can only see one
name tag no I don't see one is that is
that Yeti it's gonna I'm standing gets
Yeti and I go steady they do pokeball
Wow what what what came out of it it's
lime oh nice don't know don't know why
but hey hey hey oh that that's an easy
way to get hit off the map i'm not going
that direction yeah i'm not i'm not
going oh is that is that lamber is a
labral you you run on the hilltops in
front on the hilltops i'm i'm on the
ground right now oh sure your heartening
ride don't mind me what's gonna happen
if we wish I get Teddy I'm all for that
I only have like two lives left oh yeah
sure yeah I have one empty I guide I
need you I need you guys she team
against everybody else oh yeah we eat
with everybody we need a team everybody
against Eddie is my hopeful gaining on
yeah everyone against Eddie no yep we're
so steady here like
this is kind of saddening yep our Teddy
where to go others teddy now I'm doing
this for Mother Russia the mother russia
about you just get all the hits oh oh oh
I just I just get insta-kill that's nice
am I gonna be small killed oh hello oh I
find Waldo just jumped off the edge and
Teddy just fell into lava man everyone's
doing great oh it's a fight it's a fight
between Waldo and land and Teddy up to
oh oh oh no Teddy's down all right it's
a one-on-one halls all the ones were all
nope no screw you the call messin me up
up Waldo look behind you yeah yeah yeah
I know oh my gosh Oh back back it up no
no no oh my gosh oh my I knew you were
camping somewhere are well I got third
so it's the thing yeah i know i saw you
on the hilltop you just hit but above
wold over 16 years I had one mile are ya
I'm not doing any more community maps
water let us get a whole life and let's
do this all right well that's third so
that should give me another two points
so i should have eight points I should
have a ballistics out like really
alright guys I'm gonna go back any other
call everyone I hope you enjoyed this
third round fourth round rate awaits us
soon and I'll see you all later peace
hello try to win alright we go play
village yeah planet village what is this
bone 20 the bonus we're fighting okay
something earlier oh whoa what what what
is that what she does that what kid is
what I'm talking to Leo Oh Jeb judge can
you get to work for you I oh gosh oh
oh oh my I just I didn't see you for the
majority of that did I did I seriously
spawn two inches from you that double
jump though oh the whole gangs here I'm
gonna go the other way I had slowed
balls oh I got shot right there wow that
hurt okay Oh No get over here little ice
cave up here I've I've never had the
jibs call work oh I'm not you this is
the closest one to you I was Wow oh okay
why are we all striker goddamn hey like
striker get some carrots running
grinning grinning oh I'll just be
sitting up here sniping I got a hit yeah
and I lag like horribly almost died ouch
oh dang dang I made you not be into leo
can you stop shooting me get strike oh
dang it dang a my mom my sword to not do
what it should have whoa wow you kill me
in like two hits there what the heck
crits crits pro I'm not doing well was
above you I thought but hey I'm not that
great of a Bowman doesn't work how are
you guys the same kit yep here's most
dombey's dude we played it around
earlier at all four of us were withers
are the gun not even playing I lost that
one okay bye
yeah I don't know how we got all with
this I was just that just happened yeah
yeah we were just like hold on oh
there's another wizard oh there's
another with her Oh are we all Withers
what I know that ridiculous but that's
what danke loss okay uh oh crap in
someone kill striker we should really
kill striker oh gosh oh come on come on
come on let's check it here oh oh no aw
dang dang all right Oh angry potatoes
one show your I saw that too oh I was
awesome epic trip movements whoo oh hi
hello oh hey what's up my phone oh ok oh
oh god no no I think I lost oh man I did
so much better in the first game I
outlaw last place dang you to get
stricter alright guys I hope you have
enjoyed this game as they continue
fighting and we'll probably have a group
outro but now hope you enjoyed it did
leave a like rate comment or subscribe
got to the end of the video i were to
think you guys would have liked enough
to slow leave it a like at least so
that's basically that and hopefully will
do more tourneys in the future our gas
peace out all right guys here we go we
have done all four rounds and we are
about to hear the results so coming in
at last place we have Matt I got six
points coming in good job 77 points we
got a kiss
yeah well eight points in a tie between
Gage and DJ yeah yeah let's all clap ya
comin in with a nine points we have
Luigi and toaster nice and we have a
four-way tie for what is this first
second third fourth fifth place we have
Waldo dark alpha and wabbit with all ten
points yeah all by himself in fourth
place we have Leo I was all by myself
and certainly come again at third place
we have a three-way tie between myself
Christian and crazy at least in Dickens
nice job a job ok talk to that second
place with a grand total of thirteen
points lemon ma DG and coming in at
first with 14 points be a pity yes ooh
gg gg all right guys Luigi here
prestigio matter what I'm out of
multiple names alright guys I hope you
enjoyed this tourney it was a lot of fun
I did better the first half and the
second I've second I've kind of pooped
out but I hope you enjoyed it if you did
make sure you as i said in the end of
the previous video leave a like or a
comment or subscribe I'll we're
definitely gonna be doing more attorneys
like these and it's on a fun they have
some we have a servers server or servers
going my sure how many but I know of at
least one and so maybe I'll join that I
know I kind of had to be invited to that
so we'll see we'll see and hope you guys
just are liking all the stuff and doing
with the people yeah all right peace out
guys